so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
so um I know what maybe want to talk
about this but you know sometimes those
things pop into my head
you guys get a video on it um so as I've
mentioned in a number of videos at a
number of points I am a parent I have a
daughter she's currently seven and she
this part I haven't mentioned um she's
not into the stuff I'm into she doesn't
share my geek tomes there are things
that we both like I mentioned we watched
Hilda together a lot of the animated
films that I I do reviews on she comes
with me to see those but by-and-large
she just doesn't dig most of the geeky
things I'm into and normally that
wouldn't strike me as so odd or you know
nothing worth commenting on except that
you know when I as I look around both
with people who I know in my life and
also with you know from what I can see
of what filters back to me through
social media it seems to be a fairly big
thing with my generation of kind of
feels like a harsh word but kind of
indoctrinating our kids into our fandoms
and like I said that that feels like a
harsh word because indoctrination
carries a lot of baggage as a term but
it's kind of hard to think of what else
it could be or what else you would term
it as and I'm not gonna say that I'm
like
of that like I might my kid you know at
a month old was wearing a Doctor Who
onesie you know I she knew how to say
sonic screwdriver before she was two
years old um you know when she was when
she was really little I used to hold her
in my arms watch the the Justice League
cartoon you know she's she's been around
this stuff she knows what it is but it's
also not really her thing and I kind of
got hammered into me initially sort of
the first clue that maybe she wasn't
gonna dig everything that I'm into was
when I tried to show her Star Wars now
this was a couple years ago but we got
as far as Luke meeting the droids and
she turned to me and said can we do
something else just bored and and there
are some things that I like that you
know that we like together and there are
some things that are my geek times that
she has an interest in she's not super
into it but she does like Batman she
likes Lego Batman best but she likes
Batman um she does like Ghostbusters
she's seen the movie um I was a word
that was gonna be too scary for her but
she enjoyed it but she likes the cartoon
of it better and I do have those but
even those she's not like super into
like she's she's into dogs and wolves
are kind of her big thing but but he was
the key thing that I kind of zeroed in
on that made me not only okay with the
fact that she's not really into my stuff
but oddly kind of proud of it and that
is I realized that the fundamentally
what she looks for in her entertainment
the stuff that I like isn't gonna supply
to her I'll clarify that in a minute but
you know I do want I also kind of want
to back up because I don't want to sound
like I'm bagging excessively on my
generation of parents
because you know the idea of sort of
getting your kid into the stuff you like
that that didn't start with us I mean
the classics would have been you know
I've got how many how many people of how
many people of any age mostly guys but
like how many sons were sort of
indoctrinated to certain sports fandom
by their dad often a sport that they
themselves played at some point in their
life that they really get their sons
into you know that that sort of thing or
you know people really into cars kind of
want to teach their kids how to be into
cars you know fishing wasn't whatever
then so none of this is new I think the
difference is though is that with my
generation a lot of the stuff that we
wish to pass down is considered or was
until recently to be childish things
so whereas as an adult it was acceptable
to root for sports team until fairly
recently it would be a point of mockery
if an adult person you know had Star
Wars toys hey you know was playing video
games but things have shifted where
that's that's now acceptable as an adult
but these are still also they were for
us in our childhood and they're still
here for our kids to enjoy and it hasn't
really happened with entertainment like
this or on this scale before and also
kind of uniquely for my generation a lot
of the stuff that we loved as kids like
the real specific stuff is still around
and not just in the sense of like oh we
can watch the old things I mean like
they're on what like their fifth Ninja
Turtles reboot there's new spider-man
there's like all this stuff is Metin
there's new ducktales you know so we the
the nature of the reboot culture gives
us one more way to sort of bring our
kids into this and again I don't want to
say that's necessarily a bad thing
I'm saying when I say that I'm okay or
even kind of proud that my daughter
isn't it's not because I feel it's a bad
thing to get your kid into your geek
dumps but what I clued in on and this is
me like sort of stepping out of the
bigger picture of broad strokes and
making it much more personal what I
clued in on is that what my daughter
likes in her entertainment is that she
likes emotional resonance she enjoys
connections between characters she
enjoys emotional resolutions much more
than combat so what the upshot of that
is is anything that is resolved in a big
fight if it's being done like sometimes
if it's a big fight but it's funny you
know Teen Titans go Lego Batman she can
go for that but if if the thrust of the
conflict in the way that it's intended
to be resolved is through combat she
kind of gets bored she like I mentioned
this before right as of right now and it
has been since we saw in the theater her
favorite movie of any movie is a wrinkle
in time which is a film and a story that
ultimately climaxes and resolves on one
character telling another that they love
them her favorite part of Moana is the
very end where Moana stops a monster not
by fighting it but by understanding its
pain and making a connection with it
that's the stuff that speaks to her and
it shows a a desire for an attraction to
empathy that as a parent makes me just
kind of just makes me feel really warm
and really proud of my daughter
and it's made the pillow a little bit
easier to swallow the fact that she's
probably never gonna get into the
majority of stuff that I like because
most of what I like ultimately is in
some way combat centric Star Wars is
combat centric superheroes for combat
centric indianajones combat centric Star
Wars Star Trek rather one could argue
wasn't always combat centric but they
still usually tend to climax and some
kind of action saying you know the good
guys win when the bad guy dies even if
it's not by a fistfight and I might try
am I trying to get her into Doctor Who I
think she might be a little bit more
interested with Whitaker and the role
but even that like she's kind of I also
don't think sci-fi in general is her
thing which would be a separate thing
but it's it's funny because it was
something that initially I worried a
little about because I wondered you know
are we going to connect because I can
think about the stuff that my mother
introduced me to that I loved which
includes Star Wars or heck it's stuff
that I love that I used to do with my
grandma you just play Nintendo with my
grandmother I used to watch Star Trek
The Next Generation with my grandfather
a lot of the lot of memories and a lot
of connections are built around that and
I had for a little while a fear of not
having some you know some of the things
that that it could build memories around
with her you know around shared loves
like that but recognizing what it is she
likes is actually what got me to push
her to try Hilda because when I finished
it even though I liked it but didn't
love it
I finished it the show about a young
girl who seeks to understand things and
and help them more than like forcibly
stop them and I knew she'd love it and
she did
can't get her watch Shira but she loved
Hilda and I knew she would because I get
her better than I used to and even if
that means that she'll never go with me
to a Marvel movie premiere and you know
at the theater or whatever that is okay
because I haven't got a pretty awesome
kid and this yeah this has gotten a bit
personal I hope folks don't mind too
much and before anybody asked no no
she's not gonna be appearing on camera
she's too young for that when she is old
enough that I feel confident that she
understands the consequences of actually
putting yourself out there on the
internet and she expresses a desire to
actually do it so far she has no
interest in this end of my life
maybe then someday but no not anytime
soon so that's that one that's me just
kind of having a happy dad moment on
camera self-indulgence I don't know
whatever your thoughts were on this drop
something out in the comments let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff that you
can do because it's buttons there's
links there's patreon which is
incredibly helpful
the reason this video looks the way it
does is because I was able to get a new
camera and that was possible because of
that so much appreciated to those who
already do please check it out if you
haven't there's other links to look at
besides that if you want to but even if
you don't that's okay because at the end
of the day you are the count
so I just run the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]